[Arabic recitation]
we want to speak about something that
can be viewed as basic.
Often times people will
dismiss
the most important and critical
components of Islam,
the things that
our very souls depend on getting right
in order for us to obtain salvation.
Many times people will dismiss these
things as being basic or fundamental or
easy.
We want to start with a verse of the
Quran
in Alan.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala commanded us.
He said,
He says subhanahu waala be
he has commanded us in general and
specifically the scholars of this
to be
he said bean
in the Arabic language is taken from the
root word
and it's taken from the same origins
that the word is taken from
is to cultivate something to bring it up
from a seed
to a sapling
to a tree
to a tree that bears fruit. This is
called what tia
rearing,
raising, cultivating.
Now Allah commands us all but
specifically the scholars of this to
be
and that is that they raise the people
the hearts and the souls and the minds
of the people that they cultivate the
people's souls and minds and hearts the
same way that a farmer would cultivate a
seed.
You water it. You weed around it. You
get rid of anything that would you
know that would smother it. You protect
it. You review it and you watch it grow
and you help it to grow.
The scholars of this they do this.
They do it with the souls and the hearts
of the Muslim, the rest of the Muslim.
And who is the one that did this for the
scholars? Because we have a principle.
It's really a principle of logic. And
that is
someone who doesn't possess something
can't give it to someone else. In order
to give something to someone else, you
have to possess it first yourself.
Where did they get their from? The
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's sunnah.
And they were raised by the one who were
ra by the ones who were raised by the
ones who were raised by the ones who
were raised by the companions who were
raised by the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam himself. It is
a tradition. It is passed down from
generation of scholarship to generation
of scholarship and it is documented
meticulously in their works and in their
literature.
And so how do we do this tba? How do we
raise and cultivate and rear the souls,
hearts and minds of people
the same way we do their bodies. When we
have a newborn,
we
cultivate and rear this newborn by
protecting it and giving it what
nourishes it. What will nourish it?
Something that probably wouldn't be very
nourishing to the to an adult. An adult
isn't going to be sufficed by milk. An
adult is not going to be sufficed with
baby food. We are as adults much more
sophisticated than that. Our bodies are
more sophisticated. We need more
nutrients and different types of food.
But if we were to give our food as
adults to little babies and infants,
what would happen? We'd kill them. We
would kill them.
And so we have to nurture the hearts and
minds and souls in the same way. We
don't give them the major issues. We
give them the basics, fundamentals. We
perfect those things until people take
it and accept it and swallow it and it
becomes part of them, part of their
spiritual body and then we add to that
and we grow with them. So the statement
of Allah
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala instructs the
scholars to be those who raise and
cultivate the people
in the same way that a father would
cultivate his son, in the same way that
a parent would cultivate his child.
and to raise them with the knowledge
that they inherited from the book of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and the sunnah
of the prophet Sam
what does this look liked
forb
[Silence]
one of the greatest
of this he said
in this verse they are those who teach
the people the fundamentals before they
teach them and go on to teach them the
more major issues, the more branched out
issues. What are the fundamentals? If we
were to ask ourselves right now, what is
the fund what are the fundamentals of
our religion? Often times we dismiss
them as being something that is common
knowledge. We already know that we want
to hear new stuff. We want to hear
you know things that are new that we've
never heard of, things that are amazing,
things that will entertain us. This is
not knowledge.
Knowledge is perfecting the basics and
then branching off on those basics. Even
in any discipline, any discipline, not
just Islamic knowledge, any discipline,
if you want to learn how to fight, you
begin with learning the basic structure
of fighting, whatever discipline that
is, you work on it until it becomes part
of your soul,
and then you start to learn and branch
out upon that. You want to learn
marksmanship. You want to learn
mechanics. You want to learn
engineering. You want to learn
mathematics. You want to learn medicine.
Any discipline,
it always begins with what? With the
basics. And the better you understand
those basics, the better you will be
able to understand the rest of the
mechanics.
If I want to teach a person how to be a
mechanic of a modern car, a modern
vehicle, I don't start them with
a V12 complex turbocharged jet engine.
That's not what I start them with. I
start them with a very basic concept.
This is these are the three components
that go together. This is what this
does. This is what this does. This is
what this does. And everything else is
built on that. This is very important.
The other things may be exciting.
We really love to see all those fancy
things displayed for us, right? When we
go to watch a basketball game or a
football game, we want to see all the
fancy moves. But those fancy moves only
come from repetition of the
fundamentals, perfecting the
fundamentals. What are the fundamentals
of our religion? Alhamdulillah, our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam made it
very clear for us. What are the
fundamentals?
What does that mean? In order for us to
completely understand this statement, we
need to understand what it means in
itself, what it implies, what it
entails, and what negates it. If we have
to learn its contrast, what's its
opposite?
So what doesillah
mean? None is rightfully worship but
Allah.
What does that entail? It entails that
the worship of other than Allah is
strictly prohibited and any act of
worship cannot be directed to other than
Allah.
What does it necessitate? It
necessitates abandoning the worship of
all and everything else including things
that come from the worship of other than
Allah superstitions magic like
all of these things. And what negates
it? A shik a shik negates it in its many
forms.
Right now when we say
what does that mean?
Allah
remember what we said forahill
none is rightfully worshiped but Allah
Muhammadool Allah none is rightfully
followed and obeyed unconditionally from
amongst mankind except for Muhammad Sam.
It literally translates to Muhammad is
the messenger of Allah. But what does
that imply?
It implies
whoever obeys the messenger has obeyed
Allah. What do we surmise from this?
Whoever disobys the messenger has
disobeyed Allah.
Whoever obeys someone else other than
the messenger in the same way that they
obey the messenger, they have not obeyed
Allah. And they have run a parallel with
the messenger of Allah sallall.aii
wasallam.
And that is why we learn what negates
Muhammad Allah. What's its opposite? We
say that
its opposite is what
the sunnah.
When we say the sunnah we mean adherence
to his tradition. What negates it?
What's its opposite?
Huh?
Innovation is its opposite. Does
innovation exist?
Does it?
Because if you listen to anyone who
practices an innovation,
it's not an innovation.
Or if it is an innovation, it's a good
innovation. Cuz we have lots of types of
innovation. You know we have good
innovation we have bad innovation we and
some of them we have waj innovation waj
we have innovations we have mubak
innovations we have mak you know it's
innovation but don't really mess with
and we have haram innovations and no
person you have ever met who practices
an innovation will admit that it is a
haram innovation not one person ever.
So where is it? Where does where is this
innovation? Where is it? It has to be
somewhere, doesn't it? What are the
scales that we use to judge that
something is an innovation?
Well, in order to understand that,
we have to understand the definition of
innovation.
The definition of
these two, these two testimonies,
they come together for a reason
because they complete each other.
In order for me to be completely
in the religion of Allah,
in order for me to be completely
submitted to Allah, I have to submit to
him sincerely
and I also have to adhere and obey him.
And so the sincerity is inahillahill.
The obedience is inool.
What negates?
What is the definition of shik?
Directing any worship or anything that
is of worship to other than Allah.
directing any type of worship or
anything that is a derivative of worship
to other than Allah.
Now what is Muhammadool Allah? Its
opposite is innovation. What is the
definition of innovation?
The definition of innovation
is is to worship Allah
in a way
that has not been
founded by the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
That's innovation.
Notice the wording here that we're using
to worship Allah. Sometimes, you know,
you will say, well, this is innovation.
People will say, well, a car is an
innovation. Your cell phone is an
innovation. This is so silly. It is such
it it's also a very boring argument, by
the way.
However, when I have a phone or a car,
I'm not worshiping Allah by using a
phone. That's not my intention, right?
I'm talking about doing something that I
believe will make Allah pleased with me.
That's called worship.
And when I do it for other than Allah,
we call it shik. And when I do it with
other than the prophet's sunnah, we call
that innovation.
That's what innovation is. It is doing
something
to try to gain nearness to Allah
with something that was not founded by
[Arabic recitation]
And because of this innovation is many
types
and the scholars have spent
centuries over the centuries they have
documented every type of innovation that
has ever sprouted up where it came from
all the way back to the original one
person who came up with the idea. every
innovation, everyone
and where it has spread to and what
other innovations have come up from it
as well. It's well documented.
Why is this? In order to protect the
prophet's sunnah saiam
because if we were to allow people to
have their way with the sunnah, what
does Allah tell us about giving people
their way? He said,
Allah says that if the truth and if
Allah were to
follow the lead of the people and their
desires and whims, they would destroy
the heavens and the earth upon
themselves.
Their desires are illogical.
The desires of man. If we were to allow
people to have their way with Muhammad's
sunnah, they would not leave anything of
it. You and I would not be sitting here
today. If it weren't for scholars, men
and women who bled for this religion to
keep it pure and to bring us here today
in this masid to be able to discuss the
prophet's words and sunnas and even talk
about his breaths and how many white
hairs were in his head is because men
and women bled to keep that pure. It
didn't just come from nowhere.
There were men that were put in prisons,
men that were murdered, men that were
killed, men that were whipped, men that
were disgraced,
people who had their entire livelihoods
destroyed, men and women who had their
children killed and murdered in front of
them for the sunnah to preserve it, to
keep it pure. And it wasn't just guys,
let's not differ. I mean, what's the big
deal? It is a big deal.
This is Muhammad's sunnah as a big deal.
Every breath he took is a big deal and
we will not allow anyone to trample
around it or to trample over it or to
have his way with it. Imagine
our prophet sallall.aii wasallam passes
away. He leaves us this sunnah, this
incredible trust entrustment.
And then we allow every Muslim,
every Muslim
to add one letter or take away one
letter of the Sunnah. That's it. Every
Muslim in history only adds one letter
to the Sunnah or takes away one letter
from the Sunnah.
What would have happened to the Sunnah
by now?
Look at the tora. If you want to see
what would happen to it, look at the
Torah.
It's estimated that over a third of the
Tawra has been changed entirely
and the rest of the 2/3 has been
altered. That's what they did with their
book. We will not allow that to happen
to our prophet Sunnah. We will die a
thousand deaths before we allow someone
to have his way with the prophet
Muhammad's saiam.
And that is how you love the prophet
Muhammad. It's not just by saying it or
writing a poem about him or that's not
or or reading nice stories, right? But
then we read all these nice stories
about how great he was. We close it and
then we follow someone else and we
worship Allah with someone else's
sunnah. How is that considered to be
love of Muhammad Sam?
That is not love of Muhammad.
Say if you love Allah truly then follow
me and Allah will love you in return and
forgive you your sins.
if you truly love Allah.
So we have a very strict policy
with regards to the prophet's sunnah
sall.ai Wasam.
We don't allow anyone to meddle with it.
Whether he be a scholar, a saint, an
angel, a devil. No one is allowed to
meddle with Muhammad Sunnah. No one is
allowed
to be beyond reproach. Every single
scholar
is bound by the question is
every scholar is bound by the question
what is the evidence for this everyone
and if he cannot provide a clear
evidence for it
then this is a problem and this is
exactly what we call innovation
but if you want something you'll find
someone to tell you It's okay. You will.
No matter what it is. Do you want to you
want to dress up for Halloween?
I could give you 10 videos now on
YouTube, right? The devil's den. I could
give you 10 videos right now of big
scholars and Islamic ortors that will go
on for an hour and two hours speaking
about how Halloween is actually okay.
It's not a big deal.
You know what else do you want? You want
to you want to celebrate Christmas?
Give you evidences for that.
You know, yeah, Christmas, it's not
really a religious holiday anymore and
most people in America aren't really
religious anymore and it's more of a
cultural thing. Now, you see where we're
going? And then you'll have Christmas
trees. And I have seen Muslims that have
Christmas trees in their homes and
there's no Christians living in there.
It's only Muslims.
And I've seen
Roman trees in the shape of a crescent
that is exactly a Christmas tree
that Muslims have in their homes.
What is this?
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us and
abandon entirely. Turn away from those
who have taken their religion as an
entertainment and a source of pastime.
They're not of you, oh Muhammad, and you
are not of them.
That's not what our religion is about.
Our religion is very very easy. What
does that mean? It's easy. It's a very
easy combination.
I worship Allah alone. I worship Allah
alone in the way that he has commanded.
So easy.
Who complicates it? Human beings when
they try to stick their fingers into it.
As Allah says,
that if the truth were to follow
people's desires, the heavens and earth
would cease to be.
People would end their own existence out
of ignorance.
Human beings desires cannot be trusted.
And that is why Allah has given us a
strong and formidable
army of scholars
throughout the history of Islam for
1,500 years and until the earth is no
longer a literal army of scholars
that will protect this religion until
their dying breath.
When we look at stories Im Ahmed,
I im Ahmed Ham Malik Ib anus was put in
prison for the sunnah. A he had to move
his entire he had to move three
countries away because of the sunnah. In
order to survive, Imam Ahmed spent years
in prison. Shehikh Alislam died in
prison. Ib Kir was put in prison because
of a fatwa on divorce.
Ib the mufas
Ib
was imprisoned and he had to write his
books by a dim little light until he
went blind doing it in order to give us
what he gave us. These are these men
that and this is just a drop from an
ocean of stories of the scholars of
Islam. These are not men that were
allowing people to come in and just put
their fingers in the prophet's sunnah
and do whatever they want with it. No
way. And this whole idea of well, who's
really to say what's the sunnah and
what's not the sunnah? Cuz I mean the
scholars all differ, right? So if the
scholars differ, that means that nobody
really knows what the sunnah is. So
let's just be okay with each other.
Let's just leave it alone.
That kind of attitude, we would never
have reached this point in this masid
today. Look at the Christians.
Look at what happened to the people who
were given the book before us.
Christians cannot just go to any state
or any country and go to church.
They are so divided and their religion
is so schismed that if they choose a
church, they can't go to another church
anywhere else
because the teachings would be so
radically different. Look at their book,
the Bible.
Over 38 different versions of the Bible
and counting.
And we're not we're saying versions, not
interpretations. Versions. They have
extra books. They have less books. They
have books thrown out. They have verses
thrown out. They even differ on the most
critical verse in their book
that affirms in their minds the trinity.
For there were three that bear witness
in heaven, the father, the son, and the
holy ghost. And those three are one.
That verse, they differ on it. Some say
it's a complete fabrication, and others
say no, it's from Isa himself. from God
himself. How how can you differ like
that? How is it possible that scholars
would be so unclear about the essence of
their book that they're unsure if
something was written by a devil or
written by? How does that happen?
That's not our history and that's not
our religion.
We don't have that problem because we
have men and women that bled for this
religion. Starting from the moment that
[Arabic recitation]
received the words,
men and women bled a continuous river of
blood for this religion until today.
nonstop unending to make sure that this
religion is passed down to the next
generation complete and unadulterated.
That's our job as well. We did we can't
allow people to come in and out of the
sunnah it's a revolving door and
have their way with it. Just we
cannot allow people to have their way
with the Quran.
There is no difference. And the way that
the person who has no argument, his
reputation is always to attack the
person. So if you say, "Hey, I don't
think this is right. Is this in the
sunnah?"
They will say, "You're extreme. You're
an extremist. This is extremism." That's
not an argument. You just called me a
name. That doesn't make it go away. Like
it's a it's a it's a magic
trick. you you cast a spell and the
person turns into a frog. It doesn't
work that. You have to actually
respond to the argument
because the
is that nothing is allowed unless
Muhammad allowed it. Sallallam.
We only worship Allah in the way that
Allah has allowed.
That is the meaning of Muhammad
S.
And so we need to in closing go
back to this go back to this essence in
ourselves. Every single one of us we
have to go back to it with strength and
not be afraid of people who blame us.
Allah described the true
and said they are not fettered. They are
not refuted. They are not weakened by
the blame of those who seek to blame
them. Calling them names, calling them
extreme, calling them arrogant,
calling them misguided. All of those
names they called our prophet that
sallall.aii wasallam. Do you think if he
would have came to us today that you
wouldn't find CNN and Fox and BBC all
calling him the same names? Of course
they would. They would be calling him
the same thing that they called new
when he was building his ark in the
middle of a desert. He's crazy. He's
possessed. He's sick. He's a liar. And
anyone who defends the prophet
Muhammad's sunnah will be called the
same thing Muhammad was called.
And if that is too hot of a kitchen for
you, then you're in the wrong kitchen.
[Silence]
I know tonight we usually have a
question and answer session but we
had A bit of a change of program for
this evening. Inshallah, we'll continue
it next week.